what's going on everybody welcome to
part three of stock price acquisition
where we left off we hold the open high
low close of one day data from Yahoo
Finance we pulled it for Apple and this
is the data file that we we got here
it's about what it looks like to 49
lines of price information and just as a
quick aside oh if you wanted higher
granularity like later on we'll be
getting into that but if you want you
could edit this and say like 10 days
right and so for example let me just
clear this file and we'll exit it so now
what it's going to do is give us ten day
data which will be five minute open high
low close instead of a day so we could
run that and we just ran it and here is
our file if we edit it you know that
works as well so that same kind of
functionality that we've written will
work for you know any kind of
granularity of data but as you'll notice
again this is printing out unix time not
a date stamp so we will have to take
care of that eventually but we'll get
there so now what we want to do is let's
say you know that's cool but like I was
saying before I'm going to delete this
file you should probably delete yours as
well
what I was saying before was you know if
all you wanted was one stock of data
then you're going to visit that page
manually by hand copy and paste and
you're set but what if you know what if
you want more stocks right that's what
programming shines is when you want to
do like bulk activity so let's say stock
to pull even though this is a singular
stock to pull just just out of my own
we're going to change it to stocks
because I will little compulsive yours
anyway so we'll choose that now let's
say we want to add a few like let's say
we want Apple we also want Google we
want
foresaw we want Chipotle you want Amazon
eBay and I'm trying to give us plus I
really like um like Tesla everybody
likes to test us with Tesla
okay so we've got one two three four
five six seven stocks now that we're
going to pull and just because that's
only seven I'm going to put a 1 second
timer on there just to save you guys
some time for watching my video as you
can see we've got no files yet but what
we're going to do here is add them so
the only thing that we're going to do
once we have added those stocks to this
list what we want to do is come down
here and now we're going to make a for
loop and actually we're are going to
change this parameter I wasn't even
thinking about that whenever I changed
it but anyway now we want to do is
basically for every stock in this list
we want to run it through this function
so that's what a for loop is for so for
each stock in stocks to pull we want to
do buck tab this over pull data and then
what we want to pull is for each stock
right it's a temporary variable it's
going to assign to each one of these we
want to perform this so now let's save
that we'll move this over a little bit
so you guys can see emotional I hit run
module and we should start seeing an
Apple Google's done Microsoft's done
here we go here we go see mg Amazon eBay
and we still like one more to go or
something I don't know yeah Tesla so
here we have all of this data for one
year open high/low clothes of all these
companies so here's Tesla and so as you
can see Tesla started at 28 bucks as we
go through
holy-moly now Tesla is 161 I mean my
goodness here to date somebody made a
lot of money anyway continuing right
along okay so that's how you would do a
bulk amount of stocks if you wanted to
now obviously it's going to get pretty
messy pretty quick with these notepad
files and so maybe what I'll show you
guys is how we could do a database using
SQLite 3 if you want to do like a large
bulk of stocks but I think for the sake
of simplicity I'm going to continue
going through it like this and then
maybe towards the end I'll show you guys
how to use the database because there's
a lot a lot of things that go into using
a database and so it just adds one more
layer of complexity that I'd rather not
add just yet to people who are kind of
new to this stuff so that's how you do
multiple stocks we're going to be doing
in the next video is getting that higher
granularity of data and then I'm going
to show you guys how we can build a
script that will first of all to pull
that higher granularity of data but it's
also going to continue pulling it
continuously so run in a loop that way
you're just constantly pulling it
because if you'll notice in the API here
if we bring this down a little bit if we
do say 10 days again so 10 demon pull it
over
so you add 10 D and you hit enter as you
can see this data only goes back so far
now I guess you can't you to probably
don't know well it goes back 10 days
right why that was crazy anyway but say
we do like 22 days or something like
this let's see if that gives us anything
interesting yeah see like 10 days will
only go back I'm not even sure it goes
back 10 days I think it's actually five
days or something anyway so if you come
into this like you say you want it you
know whole months of 5-minute open high
low close data you can't do that unless
you do it over a longer period of time
but what if like a few days go by and
you forget to do it or something then
you're going to have a gap in your data
so what I'm going to show you guys is
how to pull this kind of data and kind
of make a loop out of the pro
you'll just continuously run that
program and it will continuously pull
the data and then obviously you can pull
it as frequently as you want since it's
five-minute open high low close data you
can in theory pull it like every five
minutes pull that data but it's going to
be a really inefficient when it comes
time for like the weekend and you're
like every five minutes you're visiting
the webpage so you know maybe not do
that but anyways that's what we're going
to get into in the next video so as
always thanks for watching thank you for
your support your subscriptions and
until next time